there's not a human being on earth you
saw the trailers of this movie did not
think of castlevania lords of shadow
furthermore there's not a human being on
the planet who's gonna watch this movie
and not think of castlevania lords a
shadow that's what they're going for
success Dracula untold Dracula untold
the story of a guy who becomes dragons
the origin of Dracula obviously the
movies not as bad as I thought it was
gonna be which sounds terrible sounds
like I'm on the movie right
away no one who makes a movie wants the
first critique in a review to come I was
like well it wasn't as bad as I thought
it was gonna be it sounds really bad
it's not really that bad it's just not
great Luke Evans plays Vlad the Impaler
a really hardcore yet misunderstood nice
family guy called Vlad the Impaler to
save his family in his kingdom he takes
on the powers of the dark one it becomes
what we know is Dracula it's like a
reverse Little Mermaid kind of scenario
Little Mermaid's likes you before the
Sun sets on the third day she needs to
get the Prince to fall in love with her
and kiss her otherwise she turns back
into a mermaid this one before the Sun
sets on the third day he can't drink any
blood if he does that he goes back to
being human if he fails well he becomes
a demon of the night forever that's one
thing about this movie the movies really
predictable here it is this guy that we
know of as Count Dracula has a family
and a kingdom to save it all he needs to
take on the powers of a big evil vampire
if he fails in his quest he will be that
demon of the night forever how do you
think the movie goes down knowing what
you know about Dracula uh-huh it takes
some of the tension out of the movies
you just watching the movie unfold at
this point but as a movie that's the
origin story of Count Dracula unfolding
it does have cool Dracula in it
honestly Luke Evans was good as Dracula
I was watching the movie and I was like
I don't know that there's someone else I
would rather cast as Dracula it was a
bit stoic but ultimately you're rooting
for him in his quest it's not a bad
thing for a movie like this how much
goes down and he rages out on
people he did it in all his vampire
glory Dominic Cooper plays the
in this movie I mean he was fine but I
don't feel like anyone could have played
that role I mean all you need is someone
to play a dick and that dude was a dick
not gonna stand out to me as that role
that Dominic Cooper killed it in rest of
everyone else doesn't really matter in
this vid own matter his wife kid yeah I
get it you're here to save them but come
on
drink some blood and that means
that when it's going down dude it's
going down but he is so overpowered they
need to nerf him
in really weird ways by making them kind
of stupid sometimes it shows him go out
he just slaughters this field of do's he
wife's a just our motto of guys your
whoa okay you just you're badass you
when the chips are down shade he'll just
turn into a cloud of bats and kick the
out of people that way no one could
target him at that point but then just
like oh this isn't a spoil it's gonna
sound like a spoilers really not a
spoiler you know he kicks the out
of people he shot in the trailer but
he's looking out he's like oh they're
coming in this is the last night I need
to end this tonight otherwise I fail
it's like it's nighttime there's no Sun
be proactive man just go out there and
turn into a cloud of bats and kill them
all
why are we waiting around why are we
waiting for them to come to your
doorstep just go out there and kill him
we need the illusion of tension by
making him stupid I guess
honestly it was a functionally fun movie
if you like Dracula and vampire
you're not gonna walk out of this movie
going holy I need to get all my
friends to watch that movie what have we
been missing for all these years
honestly Dracula untold isn't anything
special there's no emotional crux in the
movie you know like that damage that
Dracula has like oh man I feel that he's
just a tortured guy he didn't get any of
that you feel like he has these powers
to kick ass and entertain audiences
which is exactly why he has these powers
the movie doesn't make sense all the
time the movies really predictable if
you can think of the premise of this
movie and think oh I think it's gonna
end like this you were right vampire
fans will have fun with this movie
because the movies just made to
entertain and the end racula and told us
nothing special but Dracula untold
entertained me so Dracula untold is a
pretty good time to alcohol required
know what you're getting into I'm just
all I'm saying if you're looking for
another telling of Bram Stoker's Dracula
or somebody gonna hate it if you're
looking for a Dracula movie that's
better than Dracula mm think you might
like it so Dracula untold have you seen
it what did you think about it and
what's your favorite vampire movie of
all time whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you